um i don't think there's a version where
donald trump
wins slow is there let's see let's
review
so there are three states that are going
to count votes more slowly
um and those three states are the states
that you don't want them to be
they are michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania so
uh so you can imagine hang on one second
let's just let me let me do this for
anybody who is listening who doesn't
unders doesn't follow politics doesn't
know what the [ __ ] going on like
there's like i i want to play dumb
because i used to be really dumb
on this so just for context real quick i
want you there's so much noise out there
andrew i hopefully break this down for
you
there's 538 total electoral college
votes
you need 270 votes to win
and essentially a lot of them are
already baked so there's really like 201
votes up for grabs
because 331 of them or so are already
locked
so with that context andrew take away
um i didn't mean i meant to interrupt
you but but only because
if there's um the path to 270 yeah
completely yeah
i i was assuming that folks know that
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
are swing states or battleground states
uh and so those three states
not having their votes in on election
night
uh will likely present a problem like
it's not a situation where
you can pencil them in as blue or red
so if we're going to get a quick result
on election night
it's going to not involve those three
states right uh it's
very hard for me to imagine a scenario
where pennsylvania in particular
is just so clearly for one candidate
that they call it despite the fact that
a lot of votes haven't been counted
um i i like i don't see them calling
pennsylvania
uh or michigan or wisconsin for that
matter there was one poll that came out
that had
joe biden up by 17. in wisconsin
yeah so so it's conceivable that
wisconsin just goes so
much for joe that even with the mail-in
vote not
entirely counted that people are
comfortable calling it um still
something
i see is unlikely so election night
scenarios
you have to contemplate them without
knowing any of those three states
uh results
[Music]
joe has an advantage in paths to 270. he
has a lot more powers to get there
trump needs to essentially win every
state that he needs to win to get to
270.
uh 270s close to his ceiling there is
a world where joe biden ceiling is
350 like where he just wins by a mile
um so the main scenario for joe
to become the clear winner tuesday night
is if some of the big um battleground
states that are not those three go to
him
um so let's say florida north carolina
if florida and north carolina go to joe
then he might be able to get to 270 even
without
any of the three slower states there's
seven states i think that
really matter uh it's you just said a
bunch of them but it's michigan
wisconsin pennsylvania
ohio florida north carolina arizona
that's what you're looking at
and essentially biden wins three of
those
it's over um if he wins florida it's
pretty much
over all in right if trump if he wins
just florida
by the numbers that won't happen he'll
probably want any one of the others but
if he wins florida
it's probably pretty much close to over
um trump needs five so that's where the
like
biden is favored is because of basically
that math these are all toss-ups
leaning joe in many cases um
so i think the likely path i want to
agree with like if you like
had to guess the likely path if either
of them win um
the likely path for joe to win is that
he takes michigan wisconsin
arizona and probably pennsylvania
because in all of those he's favored
he's got
an 85 to 94
chance of winning all four of those you
know individually
um and then trump if he wins he
basically has to win
florida north carolina ohio which he's
winning in and then he'd have to take
pennsylvania and then one of
whatever's next either and you could
probably throw it exactly
so if so florida and north carolina go
to joe it's pretty much all she wrote
that's the election if so that comes in
election night then
we we go to sleep knowing that joe's
going to be um
president and uh the transition occurs
hopefully pretty straightforwardly where
if it's that clean it's going to be very
hard for donald trump not to concede
i know that some people in the bind
campaign are actually strategizing
around trying to get
a quick knockout by investing more
heavily in florida and north carolina
though they had me campaign in
pennsylvania so they're leaving nothing
to chance
that they're not right they don't seem
to be over
emphasizing the timing of the thing they
just want to win which is the right
approach
you know you're just going to win so
you've got so florida according to 538
which i think is the they were the
closest
essentially at least putting public
press outlets because they aggregate all
the polls and just do an algorithm
they're the closest to predicting 2016
they said hillary had a
71 chance of winning where the rest of
the press said it was
well in the high 90s um
they are saying that biden has a 62
percent chance of winning
florida and um 64
chance of winning north carolina those
are tossups those are you know it's
roll the die um it's gonna come down to
turnout
and possibly some you know shenanigans
with uh
mail-in voting or coveted voting if you
will
but that's where you agree i mean they
can start saying that's where we focus
and if biden wins one of those it's
great florida in particular
we're going to have a bride's gonna have
a good night we agree
yeah so that's where you should be
investing in paying attention certainly
on election night
and you should not hold your breath
waiting for pennsylvania wisconsin or
michigan and not don't worry about it
like the fact that those aren't going to
be reported
doesn't tell you that joe's going to win
or not win
uh they're everybody loses those it's
not over either sorry to be clear
like if i lose north carolina florida
you still got plenty of paths to victory
sorry
yeah and that is a possibility
historically north carolina
has been tougher terrain for democrats
and florida too slightly
i'm very confident that joe is going to
win this thing
i'm not sure if it's going to be tuesday
night reporting style
but i'm very confident that he's going
to win this thing if votes are counted
and the process
holds up uh so there so the let's
consider
again each of them in turn there are a
number of variables though some of the
variables extend
beyond election night so i guess we'll
just focus on election night so you're
right to look at the map
uh as the election returns come in
definitely it's gonna be very exciting
um but if these states start getting
called for joe then that's enormous
uh and there is a real chance that that
there's a blue wave all around the
country i genuinely think that
um in a time when 72 to 80 percent of
americans think is the worst time
in their lifetimes that that's not like
an incumbent
type atmosphere you know especially when
this incumbent does not seem like the
guy who's going to lead you out
right so i think there's going to be a
blue wave i think uh the
the democratic majority in the house is
going to grow
the said it's going to flip um there's
going to be a unified government
that's the way i think this is going to
go as we're having this conversation
like you know 75 million americans have
voted already
and by the time people are hearing this
on monday
it's going to be a significantly larger
number and then everyone's going to turn
out on tuesday
uh so you're i saw projections that said
that this
might be the highest turnout uh in
60 years because of mail-in voting
and early voting i think we should keep
mail in voting and early voting i think
it works better
i know who wants to just just have
everything be banking on everyone
showing up at the same time
one day just let us know yeah agreed
we um so you have to imagine four hour
wait in new york man
right so it's there's a lot of i'm so
glad i mailed that in
yeah so so you have to imagine an
incredibly high turnout environment
and that's generally going to help dems
so the size and enormity of the blue
wave
and whether it crashes down in places
like texas
and alaska and south carolina
georgia so interesting to me
this really could redefine the american
political landscape
uh for a long time i mean if texas goes
blue
uh well that's over yeah you see texas
go it's it's over
oh yeah that would be incredible uh
that's i don't necessarily expect that
sorry better i mean you know i expect it
to be
very very tight um but i doubt it's
gonna get called for joe
um tuesday night but if it were to yeah
it's over
i'll just call it the never gonna call
it um the
so let me ask you this like what's gonna
happen is you're gonna start
having you're gonna have what's you're
gonna have these
states i mentioned start reporting some
results because they're gonna be
counting
and i think turnout model is gonna be
all over the map right so people gonna
be afraid
to your point i think you have record i
think you have turned out like we've
never seen before from people of all
and on both sides yeah i think dems
maybe net benefit but republicans have a
lot of turnout too
if you start to see like i i kind of
want your perspective on how to help our
listeners watch the results come in on
election night when they start to see
wisconsin numbers come in
when you know they're gonna take a
couple days to tally everything
like do they like you know let's say
it's 25 percent of results are in and
they start announcing do you feel
comfortable with that do you
uh does that mean nothing because it's
going to flip the next 75
so this is why it gets very frustrating
zach it just depends upon where the 25
is from um if it's 25 from an urban area
in wisconsin
then you'd expect it to skew very
heavily democratic and then uh you take
it with a massive grain of salt
if somehow they were to say to you this
25 is a
representative cross section of the
whole state uh then statistically you
could say all right i guess we know
what's happening right that's one reason
why they keep digging into
which counties it's from because if
you're an experienced political
journalist you know which
uh which direction a county is supposed
to go
right the thing i look for is
results that surprise that surprise the
journalist involved were there someplace
and they were like well i remember
during the weekend after super tuesday
where uh they were digging into what was
happening in ann arbor michigan
uh and they were like if bernie doesn't
win this county by like a
million votes or whatever you know then
it's going to be a really rough night
um so it's that kind of thing where if
they can find an anomaly
um then that's a sign uh but the the raw
vote totals uh it's hard to tell because
you don't know what counties are coming
from
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you